Hong Kong police were alone in the
Parliament building
just hours after protesters had occupied
the legislative chamber the South China
Morning Post reported that officers only
entered after the occupiers had left
hundreds of protesters hadn't been
stopped as they smashed their way in
they want the Hong Kong government to
completely withdraw the proposed
extradition bill which sparked this
unrest Hong Kong's leader Carrie Lam put
the extradition bill on hold after
protests in mid-june on Tuesday morning
she spoke out strongly about the
storming of Parliament so this is
something that we should seriously
condemn because nothing is more
important than the rule of law in Hong
Kong so I hope community-at-large will
agree with us that with these violent
acts that we have seen it is right for
us to condemn it and hope society will
return to normal as soon as possible
protesters had remained in the streets
outside parliament deep into the night
police were surprisingly restrained in
their use of force but will that
continue if public opinion changes
and joining us now from Hong Kong is DWS
BB Kong Phoebe what's the situation on
the streets there today yeah I'm here
sitting outside the Legislative complex
which has been occupied last night and
today so we and there are thousands of
police officers now guarding the whole
legislative complex and many of them are
gathering evidence inside the chamber
and and all the difference of the
complex and there are also some
self-starting to tidy up the the role in
the appearing and right now no one can
enter the complex at all including a
lawmaker so and but at the same time we
can see there is no protesters today at
all no one is protesting or either
gathering outside that's so our context
right now so the police are they are now
at the Legislative Council building
today but where were they yesterday they
made no effort to protest to protect
rather the council building when the
protesters ransacked it have they
offered any explanation for that yeah
this is a controversial issue in many
people's disgusting hands and many are
really critical about what they did last
night and because at the very beginning
police have they have deployed a certain
number of police inside ionesco clearing
the city at night
they retreated so that leads to the
occupation because when the food has to
break in broke into the building there
is simply no police inside the building
at all so so the police explain that
because they are being there under
attack and I arrived before the
occupation and they found that it's hard
for them to deploy more process to to
the National Building because of the
some of the constraints of the
environment here so so they decided to
be sweet and then
they also criticized by some of the
total pro team of the denominator cell
they think this is a kind of tactics to
have the protesters in the building so
that is the reason for police who use a
lot more vague response like here I
guess we saw last night to disperse the
protesters those visits are very
controversial issues now Hong Kong's
chief executive Carrie Lam she has
condemned the protesters actions there
at the Legislative Council building how
hurt the protesters themselves reacted
to that for a clearing and appeal and
she iterated a few world's eyes obvious
issues with you - with joy so and she
didn't respond of the response of any of
the demands of the protesters but only
too strongly they are concerned the
balance of the protesters so obviously
she is - ignoring the elephant in the
room and she is not addressing the major
concerns of the protesters so the
protesters they are not satisfied and
this is not going to stop some of them
and this is not going to ease the
tension between the protesters and the
government
baby thank you very much for bringing us
up to date third EWS TV Kong there in
Hong Kong